j'aime pas bien je veux pas faire que je
veux juste avec un œil ça y est j'ai
perdu toute la 3D adepte de vélo de
montagne Alexandre Thivierge a vu sa vie
basculer le 19 novembre 2015 il avait 18
ans je me change quoi pour te manque à
ce qu' il y avait
un peu d'eau j'ai fait un face-à-face
avec moi dans le coma un an de
réadaptation et 6 ans plus tard il sait
que sa vie ne reviendra jamais comme
avant c'est pour éviter aux plus jeunes
de commettre la même erreur qu'il
participe à la tournée jamais sans mon
casque en partageant sa mésaventure
la tournée ça bosse depuis plusieurs
années si mon pouls là ils sont en
équipe en déjà remis plus de 6000
casques à des jeunes provenant
majoritairement de famille à faible
revenu
41 % des adolescents qui ont fait une
chute à vélo ne portait pas de casque
selon les statistiques corrigés de 2016
à 2019 cette proportion augmente à 61 %
pour les accidents planche à roulettes
de
statistiques
[Musique]
d'exemplarité donc nous les parents
quand on fait du vélo quand on fait des
activités on devrait toujours aussi
porter un casque pour montrer l'exemple
à nos enfants crèche et par l'exemple
c'est la stratégie que prendre jamais
sans mon casque des fois c'est pas
concret quand on parle à la maison mais
toi qui vois déco qui voit des véhicules
c'est l'eau je pense prennent plus
confiance exactement l'ampleur que ça
pas avoir de écouter les consignes
concernant le casque plein d'autres
choses aussi de la vie le message à
Alexandre fait son chemin auprès de ce
qu'ils entendent
pour qu'on n'oublie jamais de mettre
notre carte que c'est dangereux son nom
mais pour je pense toujours porter mon
casque et si Marie mopan brillant
Radio-Canada Saint-Augustin